what's going on guys this is rob and we
have broken seventy thousand subscribers
man it's crazy that's not salute Lee
crazy so I was going to hold this off I
meant to do it at 50 and we're like
20,000 beyond that now and so I was like
well maybe I'll wait till 100,000 but
you know what [ __ ] it we're not going to
wait we're just going to do it now so it
8pm tonight it is currently 2 p.m.
eastern standard time and I'm watching
lost still I'm reusing a show and and
we're going to do a live stream Q&A
session at eight o'clock I don't know if
anybody even turn up for it or if it'll
be like 10 people but if you guys have
questions stuff that you want answered
anything about anything Marvel Comics me
in general whatever I'll do the best I
can to answer those questions so here's
hoping that people show up and and yeah
so a p.m. eastern time it's currently
Sunday November something-or-other
second or something like that I don't
know but uh but yeah so yeah it's not
for a second so I'll catch you guys
later peace